[Music]
i'm dotier
i have a channel on youtube called
dodier wonderland
where i do doll restorations this is a
1964
ponytail swirl barbie they had a limited
run of about two years they were
basically the last dolls to represent
50s glamour it makes them really
valuable to collectors the hair is
basically a mess it's frizzy
the paint has basically chipped away she
has a bald spot which i'm going to be
filling in
[Music]
so first i'm going to wash the doll
using dishwashing soap and a toothbrush
then i'm going to put fabric conditioner
in her hair
and comb it through
[Music]
i use just a normal hair brush and then
i go over it with the fine comb once all
the kinks are out
[Music]
next i'm going to re-route the doll
using nylon hair
[Music]
that's a specific tool for doll
rerouting
so it's a needle that's been cut
so i take the hang of hair cut it to the
length that i need
then i put it around my finger
and using the re-routing tool i just
pick up small
sections and insert them into the doll's
head
then i'm going to glue the hair in place
you glue it on the inside of the head so
that the hair doesn't come out when you
brush it or work with it
then i boil the hair to keep it down
while i work on it
boiling water basically calms the hair
fibers and makes sure they lay in the
position that you want them to
i am giving her a haircut and putting
her hair in rollers
the hair that you order is not the
correct length you're always going to
have some overhang so you're just going
to want to cut that to match the doll's
length
i just wrapped the sections with
aluminum foil and then rolled them
around the rollers
the rollers i made myself using fimo
clay
[Music]
i go over her legs with a sandpaper
block to address the scratches
as her face has become a bit green i'm
going to counteract that using soft
pastels with no primer
the vinyl is basically like human skin
it absorbs anything you put on it
[Music]
i go over it using a mixture of red and
yellow and orange
[Music]
then i'm repainting her face using
acrylic paints
the eyeliner is
chipped so there's pieces of it missing
the lips have faded to a white which is
common for dolls like this
i use a thin paint brush so i can detail
all the makeup
these are specifically made for detail
work
then i apply semi-glossy varnish on the
paint job
the varnish that i use it just helps
preserve the paint that i applied and it
gives it a semi-glossy finish
[Music]
her nails are faded
and i need to go over them to make them
decent again
[Music]
the original hairstyle of the doll was
basically a low ponytail with side swept
bangs and a flip around the ponytail i
brush out her hair
i'm going to tie the hair in the back in
a low ponytail
then i use hair mousse to keep the hair
in place
and i hide the elastic band with a
strand of hair
then i set the curl around my finger
using hair moves
[Music]
[Music]
you